Розбита і напівспустошена. Постраждала так, що досі помітні сліди, що полишили російські окупанти.
Так 41-річна Вікторія описує Берестянку - село на Київщині,
в якому жінка живе все життя і де зустріла російську окупацію.
Втім, каже, себе вона теж може так описати після одного вечора, який змінив її життя.
Я плакала ночами і днями, я не могла ні їсти, ні пити, щоб якось це забути. Це біль на все життя…
Вікторія не одразу розповідає в інтерв’ю, що з нею зробили загарбники.
Спершу пригадує, як жилося "до" - з усмішкою, яку ховає від камери, як і своє обличчя.
Город свій тримали, господарство у нас своє. Робота була.
Я до війни працювала на пилорамі. Хотіла в дитячому садочку працювати, я дуже люблю дітей.
Це був клуб. Тут і вибори були, і дискотеки, і Новий рік святкували раніше.
Тут раніше стояли дитячі гойдалки. А руський мир все забрали.
Оцей брухт край центральної дороги - залишки згорілої російської техніки в Берестянці.
Чимало непотребу, який окупанти кинули, тікаючи з Київщини,
досі лежить просто біля зупинки громадського транспорту.
Спалені і пограбовані хати та розбиті танками дороги.
Вікторія зізнається: ані вона з чоловіком, ані хтось з місцевих не уявляв, що тут робитимуть російські військові.
23-го лютого ти їздив у Бородянку, там робив покупки, все було нормально,
24-го вони почали бомбити вже Гостомель, Бучу, в Бородянку дісталися.
Потім нас тут 3 чи 4-го числа вже окупували.
- Чому лишилися?
- По-перше, я б чоловіка не покинула, а по-друге, господарство. Я не знала, як виїхати.
Ми сподівалися, може, не чіпатимуть, може, все обійдеться. Вони ж не мають чіпати мирне населення.
Щодня окупанти ходили по будинках і забирали продукти, техніку, а одного вечора - жінок, пригадує Вікторія.
Це було 9-го березня. Першого разу він прийшов той орк перевіряти телефони, зброю шукати.
А потім вони втрьох прийшли - той самий орк, командир їхній був і ще один...
Сказали: "Ти з нами, а чоловіка - в штаб".
Саме цією вулицею тієї ночі росіяни повели Вікторію під дулом автомата.
Дорогою зайшли до сусіднього подружжя Наталії та Олександра. Господаря вбили на очах жінки.
Сюди ми прийшли вже втрьох. Я, той Олег і той Даня.
Той Олег давай стукати. Олександр відкрив  двері. Орк каже: "Дай свою бабу, і з тобою нічого не станеться".
Саша його відштовхнув, і той вистрелив. І Саша впав.
Вбивство! Убили чоловіка. А потім повели нас у той будинок з Наташею.
Вони коли нас вели, я йшла з тим орком попереду, а вона з тим орком позаду.
Я казала: "Ви нас не уб’єте?" Оце мені було страшно, щоб вони нас не убили.
Ось цей будинок. Коли я йшла сюди, я його питаю, того молодого Даню: "Скільки тобі років?"  Він каже: "19".
Я кажу: "У мене син твого віку".  А він: "Закрий рота!" Ну, він завів мене в ту дальню кімнату.
Я зрозуміла, що він буде ґвалтувати. Не могла нічого сказати, вони з автоматами були, страшно дуже було.
Він: "Роздягайся! Ставай типу…"  Там заставляв… Будем так грубо казати. Я кажу "Не можу".
А він: "Або я тебе буду до ранку ґвалтувати".  Я кажу: "Я не витримаю".
Він каже: "Або я тебе тут ґвалтую, або підемо в танк, туди в посадку".
Усе, що відбувалося далі, Вікторія вимовити не може.
Я просто боялася, що він мене уб’є. Він навіть мого обличчя не пам'ятає. Так само, як і я його.
Хочу згадати і не можу. Я налякана була. Я просто негайно вдяглася і вибігла.
Я чула, як він кричав: "Стояти!" Добре, що була хвіртка відкрита.
Якби була закрита, мені би був кінець.
Ніч Вікторія провела у сусідки. Потім розповіла про усе чоловікові.
А тоді почався місяць без сну, Вікторія ховалася у знайомих від окупантів, аби ті не повернулися за нею.
Уже сусіди знали, що зі мною сталося. На мене страшно було глянути.
Я спухла була, плакала, день і ніч плакала, я не могла заснути.
Я знала, що без психолога я сама не видряпаюсь. Бо це як карта пам’яті на все життя.
Після деокупації Вікторія побачила у селі оголошення волонтерів про надання психологічної допомоги.
Спершу набрала гарячу лінію, потім зустрілася зі спеціалістом, що приїхав до неї додому.
Розмовляли, картинками спілкувалися, спокійно, з пластиліну ліпили.
Таким постраждалим, як Вікторія, мобільна бригада психологів та гінекологів допомагає вже пів року по всій Київській області.
Сьогодні вони працюють у селі Синяк, що теж пережило окупацію.
Це звичайна сільська амбулаторія, де ми розташували наших лікарів.
Сьогодні у нас аншлаг: записалася на прийом 31 людина.
В цьому кабінеті у нас працюють психологи.
Тут ми облаштували УЗД-кабінет, і там в дальньому кабінеті у нас проводять обстеження гінекологічні.
Ми вирішили, що потрібно не просто відкрити гарячу лінію.
Можна її відкрити, але ніхто туди не буде дзвонити, якщо людина соромиться.
Тому ми вирішили, що потрібно саме приїжджати, розповідати.
Коли ти з людьми спілкуєшся, коли вони бачать психолога і поговорять з ним 5 хвилин в коридорі,
вони розуміють, що їм потрібно поспілкуватися вже окремо і обговорити свої страхи.
На такі прийоми, розповідає голова ініціативи "Ассісто", до гінекологів приходять розповісти про проблеми здоров’я
або обстежитися, до психологів - з тривогами, безсонням та іншими виявами посттравматичного синдрому.
Прийшла до нас війна проклята. Всіх нас тут замучила.
Після цієї війни дуже важко стало. Ночами практично не спиш. Заснути не можеш.
Ми не можемо говорити про конкретну цифру, скільки жінок стали жертвами сексуального насилля.
Єдине, що я можу сказати – майже в кожному населеному пункті є жінки, які пережили дуже страшні речі.
Психологиня Ірина, що працює в складі бригади з десятком спеціалістів, зізнається:
особисто вона працює з десятьма потерпілими від зґвалтувань по всій області,
у когось із колег таких підопічних від 15 до 20-ти.
На жаль, тема насилля іде поруч із темою сорому.
І сказати про це дуже соромно. І, як правило, люди приходять зовсім з іншою проблемою,
а в процесі розмови я бачу, що є певні моменти, які люди намагаються обходити, на них не звертати увагу.
Я бачу, як якісь питання особисті викликають надмірну реакцію.
І тоді, завершуючи сеанс, ці люди не виходять з кабінету одразу. Вони ще так сидять. В напрузі.
І коли я питаю "Чи щось відбувається? Є щось, про що ви не хотіли би говорити?"
Ось оцей момент довіри якщо трапляється, тоді людина може розповісти і зустрітися зі своїм соромом.
З кожною потерпілою або потерпілим фахівці проводять 14 сеансів терапії.
Нерідко це буває у підопічних вдома, потай від сусідів.
До розмови з журналістами у цьому селі потерпілі не були готові, декому не радили цього робити психологи.
Надто великий ризик знову закритися в собі,
якщо людина ще не пропрацювала проблему з фахівцем, пояснюють у бригаді.
Потерпіла від сексуального насилля може ніколи не зізнатися в тому, що з нею сталося.
Може проговорити ці моменти з психологом, але ніколи не сказати це на камеру чи своїм рідним.
Ми в першу чергу думаємо про те, щоб людина добре себе почувала, для її ж блага.
Вони бояться казати. Щоб вони не боялися, розповідали свою історію,
треба, щоб знали люди, щоб засудили Російську Федерацію на суді, щоб вони відповіли за все.
Мені здається, що вони почнуть говорити.
Вони будуть говорити, бо ми, українські люди, ми сильні!
Вікторія з Берестянки - єдина жінка, що зголосилася відкритися нам.
Ми говорили довго, аж доки не почало вечоріти.
Вікторія розповіла, що вже пройшла курс терапії з психологами мобільної бригади
і продовжує тримати зв'язок зі своєю персональною спеціалісткою.
Після пережитого розрадою для неї стало господарство і віра у власну місію - не мовчати про злочин окупантів.
Я сказала сама собі: "Я мовчати не буду". Поліція буде питати - я все буду розповідати, як було. Я мовчати не буду.
Вони прийшли на нашу землю, вони ґвалтують нас, українських жінок! За що таке?
Ми ж нічого такого не зробили. Ми мирні жителі!
Ми їх не чіпали, ні зброї в нас не було, ні військового тут немає нічого.
Вони… Їх фашистами не назвеш! Я не знаю, хто вони.
Жінкам я бажаю, щоб вони були сильні, щоб вони не мовчали про свій біль, бо це біль на все життя.
Вікторія свідомо попросила не приховувати її ім'я.
Каже, його символізм - "перемога" - має асоціюватися із нею,
жінкою, що перемагає свій біль, якого завдали окупанти.